[Music]
three years ago captain marvel was one
of the last installments of the avengers
to hit theaters before they all gathered
against thanos in end game
in 2023 the time comes for the second
part the marvels to be released in movie
theaters however it's not really another
solo movie as carol danvers will get
powerful support not only will kamala
khan also known as miss marvel join the
team monica rambo will also be making
her first appearance ever in a movie
after we already get to see her in one
division even though there is still some
time to go until the film is released in
cinemas there are already some things to
report so as not to get bored until the
first official trailer is released we
have already summarized all the
important facts for you in this video
this preview contains spoilers for the
ending of the miss marvel series so
watch that first if you haven't done so
already
one thing is for sure the movie will be
set after doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness one clue to this
is that monica and kamala already
possess their powers monica gets hers in
one division and thus has a significant
impact on the plot exactly when miss
marvel takes place is still unclear on
the disney plus timeline though she's
placed towards the very end
before we turn our attention to the
movie let's take a quick look at what
happened with the main characters carol
danvers also known as captain marvel
famously contributed a major part to
saving the world from thanos 2.0 not
only was she's equal in battle she also
ended up destroying his mothership while
she was still on earth afterwards we did
not see her in any of the subsequent
storylines so it is possible that she
rededicated herself to the entire galaxy
in order to protect other species monica
rambo meanwhile gained her strength by
passing through the hacks around
westview more than once with her dna
being altered several times she can
sense energies at very long distances
and throughout buildings and has also
managed to make bullets pass right
through her at the end of the series she
was tricked into going to movie theater
by scroll under false pretenses this one
revealed to her that an old friend of
her mother's had sent him and needed her
help this officially teased the
backstory for the marvels so now before
we get into camelot we would like to
warn you about spoilers surely not all
of you have seen the series miss marvel
yet and those of you who still want to
do so should quickly skip forward to the
cast section as we know from the finale
of miss marvel it is not just the
bracelet that grants her power the best
friend bruno has discovered that unlike
the rest of her family she has a genetic
mutation that allows her to unleash that
force in the first place whether this is
a reference to the x-men or the inhumans
remains to be seen what is certain is
that one of the two groups will play a
bigger role in the future in favor of
the inhumans is the fact that they got
their genetic mutations thousands of
years ago through cree experiments and
that the kree race does play an
important role in captain marvel on
another note doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness has already paved
the way for the x-men with dr charles
xavier in the last episode she finally
got her hero name from her father as
well he affectionately called her his
own little miss marvel and as you might
expect the connection to the marvels was
made in the post-credits scene as camila
lies on her bed her bracelet lights up
purple and she is sucked into a swirl
instead of her there's suddenly carol
danvers who stares in confusion at the
many captain marvel posters in camelot's
room
particularly when it comes to the cast
it is worth taking a closer look
naturally there are already some
confirmed actors but as usual disney
tries to conceal all content of marvel
productions for as long as possible for
the marvel specifically there are two
rumors which could be of interest
however let us first check out what is
known for certain before we start with
the guesswork
obvious other three main casts one is
captain marvel who will once again be
played by brie larson she gather pals
directly from the tesseract is therefore
considered one of the mightiest
superheroes in the marvel universe a
characteristic that many fans have
already criticized because it is
reminiscent of the superman problem from
the sea carol danvers actually seems way
too strong compared to other heroes
needless to say we can also look forward
to monica rambo who will be portrayed by
tayonna paris as before her superhero
name is photon even though she has not
been called that so far her relationship
with captain marvel will surely play a
bigger role in the movie after all this
is the first time the two will meet
again after carol left the earth to help
bring peace to the galaxy also we assume
that carol does not yet know anything
about the passing of monica's mother
last but not least there is of course
iman velani in the role of kamala khan
unlike in the comics kambla does not
have the same abilities as mr fantastic
indeed there she can make her body grow
and shrink yet the bracelet gives her
similar abilities it doesn't make her
body grow but it does create a kind of
crystal element that functions like
elongated body parts
when it comes to captain marvel you
cannot do without her old friend
nick fury samuel l jackson slips into
the role of the intelligence agency
director for the 13th time we are
curious to see whether he will ask carol
for help again or whether it will be
more the case that she needs his support
this time after all she is the one
searching for monica not him
since our youngest superheroine is still
in her teens her family is a natural
part of the story we already met the
three main characters of the pakistani
family in the series her parents yusuf
and muniba khan played by moan kapoor
and zenobia shroff and her older brother
amir khan played by sagar shahik whether
the best friend and inventor bruno
corelli played by matt lynch will also
be part of the cast has not yet been
clarified
it looks like we can expect to see two
more familiar faces from the mcu as well
the first is that of lashana lynch as
maria rambo monica's mother died of
cancer after the snap so we assume that
maria will be seen mostly in flashbacks
another possibility is that a scroll
takes her form to manipulate carol
although we consider the first theory to
be more likely one other possible
character is valkyrie from the thor
movies tessa thompson has appeared in
three marvel films so far most recently
in thorough love and thunder how her
character will fit into the movie is
something we don't know yet the rumors
about the two actresses surface when
zenobia shruff posted a picture from the
set according to screen rant there was a
makeup trailer in which the faces of the
young women could be seen hopefully we
will soon know if this is just a lot of
interpretation or if something was
indeed leaked about the cast
already confirmed as actors but still
lacking a role are zor ashton and park
sejun both actors are largely unknown in
hollywood zhang was last seen in the
handmaid's tale and her south korean
fellow has only been featured in
productions from his home country the
best known here would be the
oscar-winning movie parasite from 2019
but what about the plot of the marvels
as we know at the end of her first solo
film carol danvers set out to find a
home for the skrull who until then had
been terrorized by the kree empire we
still don't know to what extent her
mission was crowned with success however
since skrull visits monica to establish
contact between her and carol they will
no doubt play a part again it is also
imaginable that the mission will not
only take place on earth since captain
marvel has finally pledged herself to
the entire universe this would then also
be the first mission for kamala and
monica outside of earth pictures have
already been leaked from the set
revealing monica rambo in some sort of
space suit unfortunately as for the bad
guy we cannot even start to make any
guesses yet however we assume that he
will not be from earth we won't know
more until the first trailer or teaser
is released
back in 2019 already it was confirmed at
comic-con by producer kevin feige that
there will be another stand-alone
captain marvel movie however due to the
delays of recent years the start of
filming was postponed to august 2021
shooting will take place at pinewood
studios in los angeles and new jersey
the last filming location surely has a
special role since it is kamala's
hometown the actual plant theatrical
release date was february 17 2023
however this date was swapped with
ant-man and the wasp quantomania meaning
that captain marvel 2 the marvels is now
scheduled for release on july 28 2023
this concludes all the information
available to date on the captain marvel
sequel which actors are you looking
forward to the most and do any of you
even know the comics and are able to
guess something about the villain let us
know in the comments and if you like
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up see you next time
[Music]
you